Film Courage: Let’s suppose I’m at a networking
event or I get invited to a great festival
and it’s a mixer.
So someone says “Hey, may I see your work?”
And I know that it’s probably not ready,
what’s the best way to let them know that
where I am not hurting their feelings?
Wendy Kram, owner of Wendy’s LA4hire: Oh,
sure great question.
I would say “That’s fantastic.
I’ doing revisions, can I get your card
and can I send it to you when it’s ready?”
And “Can I drop you an email reminder when
it’s ready?
Sure that would be great.”
Film Courage: So you are not waiting a year
for the revision you are keeping them in your
mind…er their mind (sorry) “Hi, I met
you and thank you for…”
Wendy: Exactly and you know what, it could
be year if that’s really what it takes?
To me, it’s ready when it’s ready so it
could be “I met you a year ago at Sundance
and I mentioned a sci-fi 1-hour drama that
I have and I finally have it ready and it’s
been vetted.”
And actually I don’t even know if I would
go into all that detail but and here’s a
brief premise.”
Very, very briefly.
Executives don’t want a whole big description
because they also can be libel.
They don’t want to hear ideas in too much
detail because they are not allowed to accept
them for legal reasons but if it’s someone
that you have met and just to give the a refresher
this is the sci-fi 1-hour pilot about an alien
that comes to earth and can I send it to you?”
And they will either respond and say “Great”
or they might say “No.”
There also is another subject which is a submission
release forms because a lot of executives
will not take material without a submission
release form this is if it’s not being submitted
by an agent or manager.
Film Courage: Interesting.
Yeah, I’m wondering if people really understand
that when people…and I’ve seen that on
people’s Twitter bios “I do not take…
[unsolicited material].”
You know?
I see it all the time and for a newbie do
you think they realize the implications of
how it’s a turn off when someone says “No.”
Like that, they are reasons why.
It’s not because they don’t think your
idea is good, it’s because they are protecting
themselves.
Wendy: Right so then there are ways around
to try and bypass that and yeah that would
probably fall under a whole conversation about
networking and submission policies.
Film Courage: But for someone to respect that
when they see that someone says “We do not
take blind submissions.”
Wendy: Yes.
Well a good counter can be “I’d be happy
to sign a submission release form.”
And as I say that my disclaimer is that as
I say this I am not an entertainment attorney.
Film Courage: Sure.
Wendy: So whoever may be listening, if you
get a submission release form, I advise you
to show it to an entertainment attorney.
And it is up to you to decide whether to sign
it or not but that is a way around that legality
of them not wanting to accept that at all?